the best practices because farming
ranches are unique type of business it's
really kind of simple walk the land real
estate is a three dimensional product
many of my younger students and younger
folks are used to Google Earth and all
the other wonderful advantages we have
now with the internet and the web
however and it's not fun to walk a four
thousand acre ranch in Rock Springs in
August but you really need to walk to
land and understand the
three-dimensional aspect of that which
applies to all real estate you have to
realize upfront it's not the simple
farmer that's out there playing with
mule it's a whole new world it's
extremely complex
you've got mineral rights water rights
leases crop leases all kinds of things
that that make it important to you more
more involved in details I'm dr. Charles
Porter I've been a real estate agent
broker since 1978 that's almost 40 years
I have a PhD in economics in business
I've written a number of books about
water rights nor do I teach it say in
every University but also I've been
named as an expert witness and testified
in over 600 cases around the country of
30 years
I think one of the big reasons that
farmer Ranch products have soared so
greatly since 2007 2007 is really the
time that our our world kind of changed
so much as far as in New York and
finances at that point even though we
see this 2008 2007 when the money
started to really tighten up as interest
rates were suppressed especially the
tenure to bill rate went down based upon
interest rate controls by the government
all of a sudden farming ranch became not
a safe haven for money but also a
position that that you couldn't get
returns anywhere else the other thing is
there's a tremendous tax advantage if
you are able to acquire an agricultural
valuation in places like her County
reduces your Avalon tax obligation by
97% fiduciary duties are also found
actually three times in the
a real estate commission first in the
canons of ethics secondly under five
thirty five point two of the rules a
broker has the very highest fiduciary
that ought to wake everybody up the
third time trek tells you we have
fiduciary duties is five thirty five
point one five six in the rules which
says all agents have to be sure you do
so I've always understood in been talk
today they say you tell you three times
your fiduciary duties
you've got fiduciary duties above all
else we'll put our clients interests
above our personal interests and I think
that's why we're very unique and people
can tell me for those of you that want
further makes about farming ranch or a
more extensive class that's for credit I
teach two classes one a for an out for
our farmers class another seven-hour
credit class I have published a book
sharing the common Google water rights
in the everyday lives effects of Texans
and AM University Press another great
book for farm and ranch practices in
buying land in Texas is dr. Charles
Gilliland's book buying Texas later
[Music]